toi
quand tu es un enfant tu ne penses pas aux
conséquences tu es invincible mais
il y a quelque chose à propos de la
promesse de l'été est-ce que tout peut arriver
et dans mon cas, il y a des limites qui feignent
le talent ici cet été
ridicule ouais ça ressemble à ça ton
papa dit que tu connais un truc ou deux sur les
voiliers et
si tu venais demain
et jetais un coup d'oeil
quelqu'un à ce sujet gardez-le
caché vous n'avez aucune idée de ce qu'il est
capable même d'avoir une petite amie faite
vous ne vous protégerez pas et je ferai
attention l'amour vous coûtera plus cher que vous ne le
pensez je sais quoi faire
même si je pouvais tout reprendre le
ferait  vous
[Musique]